[Music]
all right let's go based
Russo although I have to preview to
what's about to happen because I never
knew that Eric had this opinion but we
are actually going to have a
disagreement about Russo do you think
cringe Russo would be as clickbaity of a
title
I was gonna say I was I was gonna use
that word to describe some of my
reactions to what he was saying Russo is
cringe yeah
based and underrated I mean I can tell
you I can I'm starting to see why this
one didn't win the award for the writing
contest
second place
didn't win first you know he died he's
like considered the cause for the French
Revolution and I think he died like the
year before something like that true is
he like the cause that's funny well
we're gonna get to uh we're gonna
interpretations of it but before we we
got so much leftist news and we've not
covered news in a while
yeah I feel like left leftist internet
is experiencing a sort of uh crack up
you know and uh in the post Bernie
because Cornell West is running for
president and apparently he did
problematic no he didn't do problematic
things but the party is problematic that
he's doing by the way listener work
where could we're Canadian we're
Canadian this is purely just
entertainment I wish she would have just
run in the in the Democratic primary
like I don't know I just think that that
would have been better well that's they
they asked them these questions you got
to watch like his interview on Democracy
Now or something like why he chose to go
with a third party instead of one of the
well obvious he's calling the Dems and
the GOP a corporate duopoly so clearly
like his platform is not gonna oh yeah
true to run with one of them and then he
said you know he's been on he was there
at the founding of this party and he's
been like a listed member of it for all
these years but he hasn't been involved
and so all those things that have
supposedly you know
come out about the people's party thing
uh were in his absence in his absence
and he just kind of went on about how
yeah yeah accountability we need
accountability but like we also need to
like build this movement and look to the
Future kind of stuff he had a pretty
good way of spitting it I don't know do
you have any idea what is the thing that
came out about the I just think that
they sound like libertarian Bitcoin Bros
a little bit too much is that the extent
of it or is it worse I'm actually not I
can't remember what exactly happened
all right well there you have it
listeners you came here for your Twitter
leftist news we don't know [__] yeah
exactly but we might get to know it a
little bit better because we're not
allowed outside there's an air warning
did you know that
if you're old asthmatic or pregnant you
can't go outside in Toronto because uh
nature set itself on fire did you guys
see pictures of New York though it like
it actually looks like literal hell
there yeah it's like orange It's like
got a nuclear Horizon that's way worse
there I think this is a stunt for the
Diablo 4 release
there's some crazy [__] marketing
campaign well I really want to get done
editing this and and release it so I can
go play Diablo but
you guys see the uh sorry how did New
York turn orange if the fires are in
Quebec or am I screaming just the wind
streams you gotta you gotta learn some
meteorology about like jet streams and
stuff that's like you know jet streams
go in weird directions and for whatever
reason the jet stream went right to New
York City
it was uh did you I don't know if you
guys saw like someone tweeted like I
don't know if it was an ironic like
conspiracy theory but it was like an
over it was like a satellite video of
the fires in like Quebec and Ontario and
like it kind of looks like they all
started at the same time but they're in
different places and they're like look
they lit them on purpose it's like some
kind of thing some kind of conspiracy
theory that they're like this isn't a
coordinated attack
I mean I think the main point is that
it's so dry because of climate change
yeah if you lit all those fires under
different conditions it wouldn't be so
bad so there goes that theory but no I
think it's because the Quebec the French
especially the rural quebecers they're
like
you you're going to tell me I cannot
show my cigarette at the window [__] you
I throw myself
caused by
Zuma fish so that's a very France French
accent by the way well I don't know how
to do the quebeca or okay Becca
coming up We Are Gonna Learn why the
French are like that why they just do
things break rules for the sake of
breaking them it all goes back to Russo
I guess that's true
I mean he was a big influence on the
French Revolution that's true
I don't know what Quebec was like when
he was writing I assume he'd never been
what would have been New France back
then
true
that
anyway it's on fire and you can't go
outside so yeah they're saying where uh
n95 masks if you need to be outside for
long periods of time telling us to stay
inside I wonder who's who's that gonna
upset but now now that it's for your
health instead of to protect other
people people will do it it's like now
it's gonna protect you from the
particulates even though only an n95
will do that wearing a regular mask
won't do [__] [__] except make you
look like a
a badass but otherwise it's it's it's
all the coverage you know they they
still
it's like okay it seems like we've all
accepted that climate change is real
finally even the right and yet you see
in the coverage still it's it's a it's
an it's not welcome the topic is still
not welcome they're still not going to
connect it to climate change and even
like our [__] premiere of Ontario
Ford refused to make the connection even
yeah they've said climate change is real
but it's woke so [__] [__] it yeah yeah
he said stop politicizing the issue he
said do you find it connected to climate
change you said that's politicizing the
issue I'm like yeah yeah because the
forest requires it to be politicized
like it doesn't impact like you're a
politician and this is a problem and
you're elected to solve problems how is
this not politics like I'm like sorry
who are you and what are you doing in
front of me right now on television oh
you're a [__] politician and this is
a [__] problem therefore it is
politics you can't just decide what's
politics and what's not sorry got out of
control there but yeah climate change
you made the you made the Primal error
there which is caring Eric I know I know
I did the thing that you you freak out
like the like the Scientology uh BBC
journalist who got baited same thing
with climate change well before we get
to French and all things French I
learned something about English this
week and I rarely learned things about
English because I was I was raised
speaking at a course but it was my okay
this is mind-blowing I want to give you
guys a little test
because I learned that they learn this
in like ESL classes you know when they
uh I don't know they're immigrating or
whatever you have to learn this is as a
thing that I totally know but I had no
idea that I knew about the English
language and that's an adjective word
order an adjective word order so if you
have a bunch of adjectives on a noun
there's a proper order to put them in
oh is it like like time space cause well
I'll give it to you and see if you know
like everybody knows it without ever
being taught it but people who are not
native English speakers have to learn it
so I'll give you maybe you should need a
piece of paper for this but if I gave
you a bunch of adjectives and a noun
right so the noun is alpha male
now the alpha male the alpha male is
white
um American
short
and deluded
now what's the proper adjective order
for those white American short diluted
so that would be short white deluded
American
I don't know if there I didn't know that
there's a correct order for that
but there is
I didn't know that short oh that's my
guess short white diluted American
no alpha male is the noun
oh but he is all short white diluted
American alpha male yeah just stick it
on the end
is that that's your final answer
short white deluded American alpha male
yeah that's my that's my chosen order
and that is correct
so the actual word order
there's a is opinion goes first
size
goes second then age oh actually it
should be
oh no I understand technically now
technically would be diluted short white
American alpha male
uh diluted because diluted is your
opinion of the person
but then size comes next then age then
shape then color then origin which is
American material purpose and then
qualifier so the qualifier is Alpha so
Alpha and male always have to be
together
but your opinion about it is deluded
then the size would be short
and then so so we make ESL people waste
their time learning this who cares so
stupid if you say it wrong it's very
important Eric just said it wrong and it
was no problem no because this one's
because he technically added diluted as
a qualifier to Alpha Male so diluted
alpha male could be a qualifier so it's
not
yeah I can give you another one I can
give you another one yeah give me
another example because I because I'm
not seeing the importance here at all so
this is a journal article is the noun
um it's of political philosophy
um it's new
it's boring and it's verbose
okay
so give me verbose new boring political
philosophy in the correct order
wow that's a lot
yeah those new boring boring new for
boring I guess it would be like a boring
it's new boring verbose
it's a boring new and verbose
yeah boring would probably come first
because you forgot political philosophy
as it is boring yeah boring new verbose
political philosophy
yeah like political philosophy sounds
like the noun here now or new I mean I
don't know I don't know I guess it would
be boring first I I don't know I've
never thought about it yeah well you're
correct again it would be borings first
because that's your opinion of it
um verbose is the quality so I can go
last but new new it has to be political
philosophy has to be last it has to be a
political philosophy Journal article you
can't say a political philosophy boring
new Journal article
yeah yeah no of course that's a noun
phrase that would be a political
philosophy Journal article would be a
noun phrase that when I know another
yeah in other languages they do reverse
that order right like the whatever the
[__]
terms are it makes sense because like
you know you you develop the language
when you're bored into it so you hear
you just get an ear for these things and
then someone comes along and points them
out to you and it's like wow holy [__]
and then obviously you teach the other
way around you try to like expose the
structural principles and then like fit
the everyday stuff into that but it's
like when someone comes along and asks
you the question like how come it's
always ding dong and not dong ding there
must be something in the i o progression
that is more pleasing and like I've I've
read I've seen articles in linguist
study and that sort of stuff too it's
like how come certain
verb orders are just more you know
they just sound right and others sound
wrong
even if there's no rules against that it
just silly if you just said what sound
does this what sound does a yeah a clock
make talk tick no no that's that's wrong
clocks don't make that sound
oh they don't say Tick-Tock either so
who gives a [__] well think of how wrong
it sounds if you say
um an American fat ugly guy
as a as opposed to a fat
ugly American guy
yeah right yeah that would say it would
be weird to be like he's ugly fat ass I
think ugly fat American guy makes a lot
more sense than an American fat ugly guy
or another fat ugly American but yeah
ugly is supposed to come first
American has to come last in in that one
well I I understand that part like like
that the that the subject or whatever
you I don't know I'm like really bad
with like grammar words because I always
I I I was a terrible student in
elementary school I didn't learn how to
write like I didn't pay attention to any
school so like when I got to University
I just like
I like don't know like grammar words
because I just skipped it I wasn't
paying attention then when I got to
University I just got good at writing
essays without knowing the rules behind
them well this is very easy because
they're all adjectives and one noun but
there's such a thing as like a qualifier
adjective which is sure alpha male Alpha
always has to go next to male if you're
talking about an alpha male you can't go
I get that but Alpha I don't shortmail
I would have no problem though if
someone was like
you know an uh ugly fat or if they said
fat ugly American I feel like actually
that would be what people would say even
though that's technically incorrect
versus no that is correct because you
turned American into American you turn
American into the noun but I said
America aren't you supposed to say ugly
aren't you supposed to say ugly fat
American not fat ugly American
yeah
ugly fat American piece
because that's your opinion you changed
you changed the noun to American when it
was Guy where you can't start American
guy right you can't say an American fat
ugly oh yeah right an American fat ugly
that would be weird I agree with that
that would be strange to be like
uh American fat ugly guy like you might
say like well obviously it would be
different but you might say like oh that
American was really fat and ugly that's
different though yeah anyway the meaning
is all there but the order somehow
matters and there's no I don't think
there's any reason that they're in that
order it's probably just evolutionary
yeah it's cultural but we've we've spent
some we've spent some time on it okay
that's also it's funny like when I was
in school and I was talking about how I
was a terrible student like this was the
kind of [__] that made me a bad student
too because I think I just had like an
anti-establishment kind of like
curiosity and allergic reaction to
things that seemed arbitrary so I
remember being in grammar school in
grade school and they'd be like what did
we just do it this way because that's
why and I would just be like so [__]
stupid like who cares I was like I can
remember it's like bringing me back to
being young and being like these are
such stupid pedantic rules that like
don't matter and like I think that's why
they stopped teaching it to native
speakers you started
anti-establishment and then you became a
lib which establishment today no I'm
just [__] with you today we're
talking to the anarchists how you doing
anarchists we're getting received
definitely not an anarchist no we're
getting to David Graber but starting
with Rousseau because Graber references
him
hundreds of times in the dawn of
everything so in their book yeah it's
like the founding kind of ideas or are
kind of worked out with uh this text the
origins of what's it called on the
inequality of the discourse on the
origins of inequality among the discards
and the origins rights
add those extra words in there Rousseau
thank you put those adjectives the
origin of inequality yeah among them
so this kicked off uh well I'm sure
everybody's got some idea about Rousseau
and
what he's all about I'm very surprised
to hear that Eric has never read this
before after doing a Humanities PhD hey
yeah I'd have to I'd have to go back
through my old like a history of ideas
course packs and see if I see if he was
in there he must have been in there he
must have been in there on the like
Enlightenment or the romanticist kind of
modules yeah yeah well let's let's let's
preface this a little bit because we're
today we're looking at whether or not
civilization was inevitable it's spoken
of often as if it were inevitable and it
feels like the state is everywhere that
it's Eternal that we have one political
form it doesn't change that it never
changes but this was not always the case
and that's kind of the point of the
Graber book is they had seasonal changes
they had migratory changes where the
you'd go off part of the year and become
part of some social Gathering and then
another part of the Year seasonally you
would become part of a larger group so
we have a concept of a eternal
police state and that wasn't always the
case and why are we choosing to do this
I don't know we we didn't really decide
I guess Eric decided
yeah I was pushing for it because I did
because well we've been doing a lot of
marks kind of stuff post-marxism and I
wanted to look into uh anarchism and I
think you know David Graber is uh is a
is a very good and well-respected
example but then just them collaborating
on this book The Dawn of everything
it was super interesting to me because
the timing was basically like I'm I'm
looking into material culture theory so
I'm looking into archaeological and
anthropological theories so a lot of
these things are coming up in the
specialist literature but then people
still you know in the popular
understanding or when you read the Big
Ideas kinds of history books or the big
history books they repeat the old myths
they repeat the old platitudes the old
kinds of you know just popular
understanding stories about human
development and they never criticize
those kinds of narratives or they they
interpret the evidence really really
narrowly to fit into one of those molds
and the two famous molds we have are the
Hobbes mold
where you know state of nature man
against man life is nasty British and
short and then you have the Rousseau
mold where it's the other way around you
know there's a state of innocence in
nature and then we've kind of
Agriculture is the first sort of stage
and then we slowly have to in our run
towards Freedom we chain ourselves kind
of approach and so Society has all these
issues that
were well this is this was his thought
experiment as we'll emphasize this is
not Rousseau attempting to actually tell
us about what's happened in history but
slowly over the decades it has sort of
become a story of what actually happened
even even though he announces quite
clearly he's not telling us this but it
has kind of just we forgot that part and
it morphed into one of our explanations
and people now you still you have
russoians and hobbiesians and they they
stick to these stories in various ways
and and the point is they're both wrong
they and they were never meant to be
history in the first place get out of
here I don't I don't I've never heard of
a single my entire life adult life in
Academia I have never heard of a Russo
oh I mean I have heard of the marxists I
have heard of the leninists I've heard
of the anarchist never a russillian and
actually I'm going to make the case that
this is sad we're I I read Rousseau for
this episode and I got stoked which is
why he's he's based I know you disagree
Eric but actually probably the most
well-read on Rousseau is uh politics guy
Victor what what happened yeah
yeah so I mean Rousseau is I think
really important in the history of
political thought like like Eric was
saying there's like the kind of Trifecta
of social contract theory and kind of
like theories of the state of nature of
like Hobbs lock Rousseau right like
that's always like kind of the trifecta
and I can remember as an undergrad in my
history of political thought class being
like really feeling that Hobbes was
super lame and then when I got to
Rousseau I was like oh this is so
exciting he's kind of like turning Hobbs
on his head
um
and I think he's fun for kind of turning
that idea
on its head although I do think that
there's you know not to make this about
Hobbs but I think Hobbs does also get a
little bit misunderstood like in terms
of you know I don't think that he
literally thinks that everyone's trying
to kill each other in the state of
nature it's more that because there's
nothing to guarantee safety you're just
scared all the time you don't have
security but it doesn't mean that you're
literally at War all the time he calls
it a state of War because it's a state
of Perpetual insecurity as opposed to
like actually like fighting and brutish
I mean he does say the thing like the
nasty Bruce and short thing but anyway
um that's kind of neither here nor there
but like when I teach this to students
like because I I taught I lectured on
the discourse on inequality this summer
so like a couple weeks ago and yeah I
mean I think
it raises interesting questions I think
students get excited because it gets to
the core question of what is the nature
of a human being what makes them happy
what makes them degrade what makes them
unhealthy and I think Russo has like a
very specific theory about why like we
have social ills and it's based on a
certain very strange view of human
nature and he does this by as Eric was
saying a kind of thought experiment
about what the state of nature was right
which as opposed to Hobbes being a state
of Perpetual insecurity for Rousseau
it's like not quite a Utopia but a state
where everyone has what they need like
each according to their abilities each
according to their needs or whatever and
they are
strangely individualistic though which
is very odd they like roam around alone
and like bump into each other and are
kind of nice to each other but don't
form Collective bonds until later
um nature provides everything that they
need
and though and I think like whereas
Hobbes thinks that like the main
human emotion that drives people is fear
Russo it's pity or what we might today
call Compassion
um exactly so like for him he thinks
that like it's just as strong if not a
stronger emotion than fear that when we
see another being suffering we find it
intolerable and he even at the beginning
of the discourse I don't know if any of
you if either of you noticed this but he
has a bit of an animal rights
uh argument at the very beginning of it
where he says
um
you know when you see like that that we
can see them suffering
and unless we have a concrete reason for
wanting to like for example for Hunger
like it's not really Justified to harm
animals because we can recognize their
suffering as we can recognize it in
another human being
yeah there's a lot it's a rich text it's
a really rich text like oh stop talking
but like there's a lot of good
interesting stuff that does get students
excited
and there's a lot also that anticipates
marks that anticipates Kant that anticip
like Russo not even anticipates produces
yeah produces so so it's it's extremely
influential I was gonna say this stuff
is like The Germ of darwinian thinking
because they're thinking about now
they're starting to move towards like an
evolutionary stage Theory kind of view
of society where you go from like a
primordial state to a more developed
state to like a final Advanced state
I mean it's it's definitely like the
beginning of evolutionary thinking at
least like social evolutionism and then
from there you can imagine it's just a
short leap to uh Malthus and economic
theory and then Darwin's application of
that to uh populations of animals well
this is a bit anachronistic because
there was no right or left wing until
right after he died I guess but he's
kind of the left-wing response to
I was trying to decide here is Rousseau
an alpha male or as Rousseau a sigma
male because you know besides what he
wrote he impregnated what you're if
you're French you're probably on on a
descendant of Rousseau because he
impregnated people and left all the
babies on on the church steps all over
Europe because he was uh I don't know
practicing his freedom like a little
Attila the Hun
yeah for this episode I cracked open my
copy of closing of the American mind
because speaking of
this is written by Alan Bloom right and
I mean even reading his account of
Rousseau made me so sad that there are
no intelligent conservative
intellectuals anymore
because if you look at their roster it's
like at best at the best of the
conservative intellectuals it's a
dunning-kruger convention but most of
them most of them are just shrill Ty
wearing clowns trying to grift Boomers
out of their retirement funds but Alan
Bloom was different Alan Bloom what did
he die in like midnight I mean he said I
mean he said some incredibly stupid
stuff in the closing of the American one
but yeah for sure for sure
uh he wrote an entire book on Rousseau
and yeah this brought back to my like I
read Emil by Ruth he translated he
translated a meal when he was a
professor at the University of Toronto
actually oh really I didn't know that I
thought he was at U of Chicago he was at
Cornell and then he spent 10 years all
of the 1970s he was at the University of
Toronto and then the university oh no he
went and then University of Chicago okay
no no then he then he he left and went
to teach at the University of Chicago
after Toronto but I'm pretty sure he
went there because he writes in this
romantic flowery language about the
spiers and all that so this is this is
actually why the University of Toronto
has a weird reputation for straussians
because Alan Bloom was there for two
years oh I didn't know that's why that's
why yeah and that's good there's this
residual from that I think he gives a
great summary of Russo's importance the
the main thing that Alan Bloom is like
I think patently incorrect about is he
thinks that history is just run by ideas
and has basically no materiality so
putting that aside this is what he says
although Hobbes and Locke teach that man
as rational Rousseau's rationality is in
the service of passions or sentiments
which are more fundamental than reason
so think of it we're in the
enlightenment here so everyone's like
science is going to improve Humanity
endlessly and Rousseau goes that
feelings imagination that [__]
thinking thinking through their position
that man is naturally a solitary being
results in the recognition that speech
the condition of reason is not natural
to man Enlightenment misunderstands both
reason and feeling
Rousseau's reasoning and rhetoric were
so potent that hardly anyone who thought
as well as many who did not could avoid
his influence
I I think he's speaking of the Jacobins
there
um after him Community virtue compassion
feeling enthusiasm the beautiful and the
sublime and even imagination the
banished faculty had their Innings
against modern philosophy and Science
and then he goes on to say that freedom
in Rousseau for the first time
Freedom instead of Reason became the
defining feature of man
and then of course he caused the French
Revolution because those people who did
not think took it up oops well that's
that's how that's how Russo influenced
Hegel by the way on freedom hegel's
account of friends on imagination yes
and con on freedom too Marx on private
property is the root of all inequality
it's like the list goes on I mean even
the phrasing
um this is I think more in the social
contract like the idea of living under a
rule that you that you put to yourself
that you obey a rule that's like in Kant
and that is verbatim in Rousseau in the
social contract right that like you live
according to rules that you set for
yourself right and that you can
collectively and that freedom is obeying
those rules that are freely chosen
hmm
and he's just a good writer too he's
extremely influential like and he's and
he's and he's kind of covertly
influential Victor and I are on this on
this train together but Eric Eric said I
thought this was all [__] so before
we get into
appraising his uh value to intellectual
history I want to hear why Eric hates
him so I mean I disagree with Russo on a
bunch of stuff but yeah go go ahead Eric
ah go ahead Eric I mean I disagree like
I might be on your side right raise them
expectations I
you know the the part that graded me I
mean there's a few things that that
bugged me a little bit and first of all
is probably just something I'm ignorant
about is that like as a response to a
question about the origin of inequality
I don't really understand how we're
supposed to take this answer he says you
know he says that like he's this is a
thought experiment this is not meant to
be real history I'm not telling you what
really happened I'm engaging
in a kind of a calculation yeah like a
speculative kind of method for terrible
getting to the yeah like a parable
that's what wengro and uh Graber call it
they say this was a this is a parable
that he's telling but it's a way of
getting it to the answer to this
question about the origin of inequality
and it makes
like he goes he's like I'm gonna put the
facts aside away because the facts
aren't going to help us but then
throughout I see him just making all of
these facts up like like he says a cat
sitting on a pile of meat wouldn't eat
it and it would die first and I'm like
I've seen cats eat I've seen cats eat
meat
yeah he said well he was making the
distinction between free choice and
Instinct decisions based on free choice
so as a human you know we could like see
that we're starving and we could choose
the right food even if it's not like our
preferred food whereas animals buy
Instinct have a certain set of things
they eat and even if they're in in an
abundance of things they don't eat they
won't try to eat them because they're
just com they're machines Guided by
instincts like I mean he just make he's
like I'm gonna put all the facts aside
I'm not going to do all that but then
I'm just gonna make up my own [__]
whatever fits into this like that stuff
kind of graded me as I'm going along I'm
just I just he just makes claims that
I'm like that's not true or like if you
really want people to come after you and
add to this and like go further in this
direction than you then then I I feel
like he's making a lot of he's putting
up a lot of roadblocks to that bay no
you're you're totally misquoting first
of all he says a cat on a heap of grain
not on a heap of meat
sure I'm it's yeah he gives the example
of a cat on a heap of fruit or grain
which they do not eat sure okay okay
well but that's not a fact right because
we're not arguing from Facts or anything
real in the history of the world we're
just doing this as a thought experiment
no he said attention will never eat meat
even if they're starving a cat will
never eat grain even if they're starving
and even if even if he's wrong about
that which I'm pretty sure I've seen
pigeons eat more [__] up [__] than me
the choicest meats
um even if he's wrong about that what
does it take away because his argument
is not based on these things anyway but
it just you know these these claims that
he just makes kind of just felt very
excited your [__] sources man like
what the hell are you making this based
on he clearly you've never had cats
before dude clearly you've never lived
in a city that has pigeons in it dude
have you ever seen a pigeon eat meat or
a caddy grain
yeah I the I'm pretty sure cat food has
grain in it
pretty sure all cat food's got grain in
it yes they do eat a higher percentage
of protein and fat but they do eat carbs
in fact
they don't naturally eat they've
determined dogs don't naturally eat
grain you can feed them a grain-free
diet but you can also give them food
that is like 40 grain right like like
their diets are pretty malleable
but a dog is not a pigeon or I don't I
don't know this is a stupid thing to
even have it's the whole thing about the
well no because it's a primary thing
right he makes a distinction between
humans and animals what is the
difference one chooses and refuses by
Instinct the other chooses and refuses
from an act of Free Will and then that
gets us right to the core of what he's
going to be talking about humans act out
of Free Will that's how we make choices
so so the will animals don't have will
because they're just compelled in
various directions by their instincts
they don't have this human quality of
free agency which he calls it which is
going to be like a fundamental you know
human quality you know think
post-humanism where we're distinguishing
humans from animals very sharply here so
we can make our argument so that's what
what nature gives humans and animals the
same sort of stuff but humans also have
these
other things that separate them
right so free will right that's that's
his the that stupid example I was
bringing up kind of catly was his
example of how they choose and refuse by
Instinct and not free will
they will die I mean it is it is you
know a cat will you can easily like piss
a cat off then it'll stop eating and
then it'll like get really sick and
possibly die like they will you know
[__] pout themselves to death they
will go on Hunger Strike but
is that just I don't know like that as a
as a way of distinguishing humans from
animals that seems yeah okay fine I I
give it to that it's this is all I'm not
[__] on this it's interesting you
know it's clever lots of turns of phrase
I will talk about things that I like
about it too I swear well aside from the
cats eating grain the overall point of
the thing as opposed to everyone around
him the encyclopedists uh lock in Lock
and Hobbs as we've mentioned everyone at
the time is saying science and
civilization advancing Enlightenment etc
etc blah blah blah he's pretty much the
first one to say you know what science
not not that great pretty good yeah
doesn't it was an answer doesn't really
answer human questions civilization uh
you know that's not that's not natural
that's unnatural are these causes of
happiness and and freedom in the world
No actually they're causes of the
opposite they are the cause of
unhappiness and inequality and then like
the main quote quotation that you gotta
remember from Russo is uh from what we
read the discourse on inequality the
first man who having enclosed a piece of
ground the thought himself of saying
this is mine and found people stupid
enough to believe him was the real
founder of society but how many crimes
Wars murders Horrors misfortunes might
have saved us if they just said
beware of listening to this guy uh
there's no such thing as private
property so private property is the root
of all evil and I don't know about the
cats and the grain but he's the first to
say it which is huge okay but really
interesting thing about this text
backing up from property
is like
if the problem is much deeper than that
the problem is language
the problem is
our ability to use language to abstract
away from nature
um
like all like philosophy is a problem
like uh there's actually a quote I was
trying to find where he's literally like
[__] on like thinking
he's just like it ruined us basically
um well yeah I've never this is I've
never even heard anyone say this and I
disagree with it probably but he says
language is unnatural yeah which is
really bizarre well that's um like he
he's
he makes this distinction between
natural inequality and uh moral or
political inequality like that's the big
thing two kinds of inequality the
natural the natural which is just you
know what is it difference in age health
strength qualities of Mind whatever and
then moral or political equality
inequality which depends on conventions
like social conventions it's established
it's instituted it's authorized
so he makes that distinction and then
says this well there's nothing really
you know if we we engage in this thought
experiment now like let's start thinking
about the state of nature well we can
assume that we are naturally the same we
have two feet we use our hands in
relatively the same ways we look around
us we take in what's around he says like
there's not not much difference there
but the political moral inequality part
that's what's really going to separate
us from them because they don't have you
know a social
Society they don't have a they don't
have an Institutional basis they don't
have
you know they don't have human
prescribed laws they don't have that
stuff so in the state of nature
they are like morally developed stripped
of all as he calls it their their
Supernatural knowledge and their in uh
their artificial faculties that would we
would be just like them in the state of
nature that's kind of where he starts it
all so that's like where we're we're
imagine and he says this state of nature
may never have existed we may doubt if
it had ever existed but this is just the
direction his thinking is going in it in
with it and again it's it's really
interesting yeah but and and I gotta get
to the end of it and ask all the so what
questions but like as as far as it goes
like it's pretty cool the way he's
turning around Hobbes and saying you
know just just because humans don't have
an idea of virtue doesn't make them all
bad because we don't have an idea of
Vice either in the state of nature so
there is really no distinction between
good or bad to be made there and but
what people tend to do is they take
ideas that have developed in Social
history through Commerce and
communication and then they truck them
they shift them back onto this state of
nature and then start making assumptions
about how they think or how they what
their intellectual capacities are based
on what we know now he says that's kind
of wrong so he's trying to sort of
Almost Do like a a historical epochet
like bracket all that and then just
start with a pure state of nature where
there's no language there's no Society
there's no law there's no nothing we
only have what distinguishes US
naturally from animals one of which is
being Free Will and one of is a capacity
for language not actual language that
comes later spends many paragraphs on
that but that's how he kind of goes into
it he starts it off all hypothetical all
kind of just thought experimenty yeah I
mean it's speculative but I think
I mean I think he's raising really
interest like fundamental questions
about what are the the conditions that
lead us to be the way that we are right
like so I mean obviously like from a
kind of empiricist evidentiary
perspective like it's going to be
lacking but I think like the point is
just to be like okay what are the things
that lead to envy and and competition
and misery and I think like he has a
profound account that I mean I don't
agree with it but there's grains of
insight throughout all of it and I think
you know at one point I was mentioning
before he talks about
um like language so I found I think it's
whatever Edition I have it's like 107
he's like it's evident
um
it is a reason that engender is
self-love and reflection that
strengthens it it is reason that makes
man shrink into himself it is a reason
that makes him keep aloof from
everything that can trouble or afflict
him it is philosophy that destroys his
connection to other men it is in
consequence of her dictates that he
mutters to himself at the site of
another in distress
you may perish I'm fine so basically
like he's saying it's philosophy and
abstract thought that gets in the way
remember I was saying before that for
him compassion is like this originary
emotion
for him it's like abstract thought
philosophy that gets in the way of that
and lets us convince ourselves that oh
whatever rationalize and be like I don't
need to help that person I don't need to
do that and it's like he says all those
things abstract knowledge abstract
thought separate us and I think you know
when he talks about the original man in
the state of nature as as this kind of
individualist creature which is very
bizarre I mean it's clear that humans
were not individualists ever right they
were always social creatures like that's
total [__] but
oh I I think what he has in mind is this
kind of pure unmediated Unity with
nature right it's like you're enmeshed
in nature and you have all the needs
that you want and you feel your emotions
and like your your nature
in a way that is purely unmediated right
it's like that's why I think he starts
with language as something that gets in
the way because behind it he thinks
there's compassion so we see another
person suffering we just help them we
don't need to think about it
um and I think this is like a really
interesting kind of profound way of
thinking about it and um I mean it even
reminds me of kind of a lacanian account
right like I mean lacon's whole view is
like language comes in and
you know stops us from like creates this
lacking that we are we're continually
trying to recover and I think you could
do an interesting lacanian reading of
Russo as Rousseau offering an account of
like this kind of originary wholeness
that would have been before language
kind of came in and
um split the subject right so I think
he's giving this kind of pre-linguist
account and then talking about what's
lost by having linguistic abstract
reason come in and create this level of
mediation that then eventually leads to
civilization eventually leads to new
desires right exactly like again I'm not
saying he's a lacanian but I mean it's
there's a resemblance here right for
Lacon it's like creates new desires
um that we try to satisfy perpetually
and suffer in a way as a result of them
and for Rousseau it's like this
mediation then kind of an abstract
reasoning creates the possibilities for
us to
uh you know have societies and
communities with other people and then
they get more complex and the more
complex they get the more we start to
find reasons to be envious and angry at
other people right and
I mean then the The Story Goes On from
there but but I'll stop there
and even more practically on the same
line you know Montessori schools
yeah you know what that yeah well in
case anyone doesn't know I don't know
their curriculum but I know the
Montessori school is like you take care
of animals and grow plants and do stuff
outside this was directly inspired by
Rousseau because you're this this
brought to mind because you're talking
about this abstract language or even
like maths or Sciences the way that we
sit in desks and learn this abstractly
and then get tested on it Montessori
education I think it was uh what I
forget her name
her name was Montessori and that's why
Montessori schools are named as such but
the thing is you have to follow your
passion otherwise you're not going to
learn anything and this abstract way of
thinking rational thinking is the thing
that gets in the way of the passions so
if you're passionate about reason then
good for you you're going to do well in
school if you're not
then you're not gonna do well in school
but Montessori education is about
getting your hands on stuff getting
involved in this
kind of a regionary state where you let
sentiment guide pedagogy instead of
letting pedagogy I don't know control
sentiment by sitting at a desk and you
know learning things abstractly so this
is uh it has like cash outs lots of cash
outs here's where
you're saying yeah earlier Alan Bloom
and now you're talking about passions
again so yeah he says I mean he's he
thinks of passion as the driving force
behind reasoning and understanding like
that's what passion does is it is it you
know it's the impulse behind the
development of knowledge
yeah he says here here's the quote this
this is a nice this would be nice to go
with what you were saying with Bloom too
the human understanding he says is
greatly indebted to the passions which
it is universally allowed are also much
indebted to the understanding okay so
there's a two bit of a two-way street
There It Is by the activity of the
passions that our reason is improved for
we desire knowledge only because we wish
to enjoy and it is impossible to
conceive any reason why a person who has
neither fears nor desires should give
himself the trouble of reasoning without
fears and desires we shouldn't trouble
ourselves with reasoning passions uh
have sort of two ways they work uh we
cannot desire or fear anything
except from the idea we have it half of
it the idea we have of it on the one
hand or the simple impulsive nature on
the other hands now Savage man is
destitute of all intelligence Savage
Savage people are are stupid and and
simple and and okay fine they can't have
any passions based on the ideas they
have of something they can only have
passions based on simple impulsive
nature yes and that's better for him but
either way so that's that's going to be
the germ I guess you have these simple
impulses and they are the sort of behind
your passions and eventually you kind of
you're able to fulfill your needs so
like why go any further why think about
things when you can fulfill these
impulses it's when these impulses sort
of complexify and present us with
problems that's when thinking has to
sort of begin and that's when everything
kind of starts going to [__] as well but
you know if you don't have any ideas you
can't have passions based on ideas you
can only have passions based on natural
impulse like the desire to eat such that
the Savage man's desires never go beyond
his physical wants quote unquote so
that's how that that's how passions fits
into the story and well I think it's
very well said you should not ignore the
role of the passions in knowledge and
understanding nor vice versa kind of
with the thing that you're missing a
little bit though is that the Savage
person The Savage man is happier than
the Civilized one yeah
you're saying this as like because
obviously he's being he's being
chauvinistic of course uh towards like
what he calls primitive civilization or
primitive social Arrangement but he also
thinks that they're more happy
no he thinks they're better I mean
that's where the noble savage thing
comes from I mean like they're better
off they're they're Sim they're simpler
morally and politically but then that is
also like the part of their strength
but it's better you know they're all
undifferentiated kind of mental state
they live in as well which is sort of
I mean it's it's a double-edged sword
kind of because you're uh quote the
destitute of every species of
intelligence in that state which so you
can't even really grasp your own
situation in that sense
and yet you're more content because
you're not you know
why why think if it's just going to
cause you problems anyway well this is
why he's this is why he um I think this
is where his individualism comes into
because
he doesn't just think that like you're
more content but he also thinks you're
more self-sufficient like so he thinks
that like modern human beings in
Civilization makes us have all these
passions and weaknesses
but it's like when you're solitary and
you just like you can hunt and find what
you want you can eat the fruits and you
can [__] someone when they come along
and like you have everything that you
need and you are fully self-sufficient
so like and that for him is like I think
the Pinnacle
of the human animal is like this
individualist being able to take
advantage of everything you want now the
story does get slightly complicated
because when he gives his story about
the development of civilization he also
kind of talks about a more realistic
kind of
um intermediary stage
which is where he talks about The Rustic
Huts he's like you know actually like
maybe the most realistic and best state
is when we lived in rustic huts with
other people small communities because
it was like kind of a nice combination
of still being really self-sufficient
but still enjoying those kinds of
passions that I think you're talking
about Eric where like you have Community
with other people
um and there is like some abstract
thinking but it's really like a much
simpler quainter quaint or time I'll see
if I can find the quote where he talks
about rustic Huts because like it's it's
kind of an important thing for him
and then we get all of civilization with
its with its conveniences with its uh
like division of labor especially where
you don't have to do everything for
yourself you get other people to do
things and then you do things for them
and then you're less happy
and you're more dependent on others so I
found it by the way so he says okay as
long as men remain satisfied with their
rustic Huts as long as they were content
with clothes made of it made of skin of
animals sewn with thorns and Fish Bones
as long as they continue to consider
feathers and shells as sufficient
ornaments and paint their bodies
different colors blah blah blah you know
um and stuck to such Arts as did not
require the joint Endeavors of several
hands right that's key so it's like as
long as they live in these communities
where all their Arts were things that
one person could do they lived free
healthy honest and happy as much as
their nature would admit and continue to
enjoy with each other all the pleasures
of independent intercourse so the idea
there is like
you can find the state where like you
are living with others but everyone in
that Community is still self-sufficient
everything they have one person can
build and yes pills is absolutely right
it all goes wrong when you have a
division of labor
of Labor but but the division of labor
and private property kind of go hand in
hand because it's like
the division of labor is possible
because of private property to a certain
extent because they're able to like
build things and harvest things at a
more mass scale right so it's like and
that obviously those two things kind of
go together and that's basically the
moment when humans became
beta simp cucks who can't do anything
for themselves
and I think it's a private property
comes from agriculture too yeah exactly
it's like the this is what like if we
get to the the Graber uh wengro book
probably next week this is where they
say this story is kind of wrong and of
course there's holes in this story it's
a little bit wrong but the significance
the context of what he's saying that's
so important the first political
philosophy the first any type of
philosopher to ever say you know what
civilization is not better for us it's
actually worse and that's why he's so
significant because so many thinkers
after him pick this up in different
directions and say you know Society this
part is bad that part is negative we
have no Freedom so everything that comes
after is a result of him for the first
time being
a critical theory he's the first
critical theorist yes he's the first
first first real critique of modernity
yeah I I can appreciate that hugely like
all the like you know you don't need to
think too hard to to understand that
he's saying like these are social
problems right they're socially created
problems which is you know a very good
sociological preparation for Marx
because
all the issues that we are currently
facing many of them including climate
change whatever [__] it's due to social
activity right it's not they're not
natural problems as we would naturally
in lots of quotes but you know he's he
it's a blessing and a curse he's the
origin of that stuff but he also
emphasizes these ideas like you know
there are certain people who still
continue to exist in something like a
state of nature and like he he kicks off
a lot of bad stereotypes so you gotta
take the good with the bad here and
that's what the dawn of everything is
going to emphasize because what what
this this narrative this narrative
there's lots here and it's interesting
but it kind of collapses into a
caricature where either you have this
you know this these perfect egalitarian
societies
in the state of nature and then somehow
agriculture happens and then private
property comes along and then you get
inequality and they're going to question
that story they're going to say there
was inequality in the state of nature
there is inequality after and there is
equality on both sides as well and
there's no reason to think that
inequality emerged at some point and
even worse to think that it merged at
some point in a linear evolutionary
narrative that goes from Villages cities
to States or goes from agriculture to
this and that like these different you
know evolutionary ecology or or social
evolutionism or any of these different
linear narratives he's going to say
those are all wrong
I mean they're not they're not wrong but
they present elements disconnected
elements of of the picture I mean I
agree with you it's just I think you
have to hold these like older you know
18th century texts to like a slightly
different standard in the sense of
like it's not about excusing at all like
the stereotyping Memorial but it's more
like even on the speculative stuff it's
just
you know this is I mean all these
[__] thinkers from that time said
crazy things about like they didn't even
have archeology as a discipline it's
kind of I mean where do you expect them
to get their evidence from Hobbs is [__]
is crazy like all these people writing
at this this time were crazy
um in what like the the claims that they
would make but very bold you know they
just like they each have a theory of
psychology that intermixes with their
political things philosophy they go into
like aesthetic it's just you can do
anything go anywhere
they have speculative courage that does
not exist anymore
so I think we read them way too linearly
like as I mean people do this with a
Hobbs especially like Hobbs thought it
was like no he he says at the beginning
I'm not even saying that it was really
like this I'm telling you a parable
about human nature
and why we need the king in his case no
that was the uh what I was trying to say
yeah I'm not saying I had a problem with
them directly I'm saying that the the
two narratives that Rousseau and Hobbes
have gotten us have flattened out and
become almost like an either or either
you know the real state of nature quote
unquote like the the narratives have
been literalized as well they're not
just taken as Parables anymore they're
taken as like literal guesses at what's
happened
uh and they flattened out so you have
these two options state of nature bad
Society good or state of nature good and
innocent and egalitarian society you
know introduces all these issues and and
stratification and inequality and he's
saying those are the two choices if
those are the two choices then they're
both wrong yeah sure sure but he's
saying they weren't even presented as as
a problem like that by the original
thinkers too that's they they vindicate
them on that ground that people are
reading them wrong and literalizing what
they're saying I agree I think that's on
us for being bad readers because we take
everything as a claim position argument
as opposed to
hmm let's sit back and consider human
it's like the same thing it's the same
thing with reading marks right like he
makes a lot of claims about you know he
Hedges what he's doing in capital quite
a bit like I'm introducing I'm
interested in capitalism and it's pure
form which doesn't really exist but like
you know and then people forget those
qualifiers and then they just take it
the word as describing reality and
that's when it becomes you know that's
when the misreading can get a little bit
dangerous because you're starting to
take the what they're saying is
historical fact rather than again a kind
of thought model thought experiment kind
of thing
so like I can appreciate these texts to
that extent and I and most of your
defenses have been sort of the broader
you know these the first to do that or
like look at this tradition and that
tradition that they've led to but then I
put my eyes on the page and I start
reading and they glaze over because it
just feels like he's recycling again not
his fault but he's just recycling
cliches what are cliches to us now
anyway for to them sure it was [__]
wonderful and new but to to me it's this
is just like the uh the walruses in in
South Park pulling out a bunch of
stereotypes and sticking them into a
narrative and it's it's to that extent
it's it's [__] but to the extent
that it's like you know social
philosophy social theory like sure great
I I probably have a job today because of
Rousseau so thanks buddy yeah he
invented the social sciences also pretty
much yeah I mean I mean I kind of just
think it's it's
he starts off by saying the three the
three inscriptions on the Temple of
Delphi are probably better than all the
social theory and moral theory we've
come up so far which is like what were
they know thyself the first uh the
moment you make a promise is the moment
Calamity is going to happen and and uh
all in moderation something about
nothing too much I think it was
I mean those those tenants are better
than all our moral theory so far he kind
of he's trolling though he's trolling I
mean I totally agree with your critiques
like obviously I don't I'm not even
defending his claims I mean his claims
are clearly wrong but I just feel like
when I'm dealing with people in this era
it's like what are the gems that you can
you know get out of this way of thinking
right and and to me it's like a critique
of modernity it's even getting into the
deep philosophical level of like what
role does abstraction play in our psyche
right and like how could that contribute
to unhappiness
um and then it's also asking us to Think
Through yeah I mean in the critique of
modernity but specifically like why
you know like like what effect does
civilization have and just like question
you know narratives of progress like all
these things I think it gives us early
ammunition for those things and like
yeah I mean I guess that's just a way of
saying like he was the first to do it
but I think um there's also like
interesting valuable work to be done
from just like getting to those gems and
being like look they were thinking about
these things back then uh and to some
extent some of the ways that they're
being framed well on the one hand
there's like incredibly stereotyping and
like stupid ways of doing it but also
there's like a kind of speculative
courage as I was saying before of like a
way of just like thinking about things
comprehensively that we don't do anymore
and I think that's fun it's fun for that
reason
I wonder about him getting second place
because this this thing was submitted to
an essay contest and he got second
so if it got second it can't be like
that outside of the norm or that deviant
or subversive maybe
yes I got this this had to be like a
current of thought in some way at least
yeah I forgot to check what the
reception was like but um well he's the
one who made it a pretty good design the
Canon you know yeah he didn't make it
onto the cannon so that's that's good I
mean and if we had more time I think it
would be interesting to talk about
how like what he tries to do on the
social contract which is like basically
come up with a modern solution to all
these terrible social ills which ends up
also being totally insane like in
contradictory like I mean it's a social
contract it's like everyone needs to
agree to the general will but they can
also be wrong about what the general
will is if like they don't agree with it
it like makes no [__] sense well
Robespierre took it didn't Burke have a
whole bunch to say about Rousseau for
like causing the French Revolution which
is in his mind the worst thing that has
ever happened yeah yeah yeah I I also
lectured on Burke recently and it was
fun he does he does [__] on
Russo quite a bit but one thing that
they kind of have in common
interestingly is like they both kind of
hate abstract thought for different
reasons like like Rousseau hates it
because it brings us to like Calamity
but Burke hates it because he thinks
that people who do things in the name of
principle or ideas are like really
idiots and that you should be doing like
that you have to take into account this
the context the material circumstances
and that like the French Revolution was
a disaster because they're all naive
about the material circumstances of the
time and we're just obsessed with stupid
principle or like lofty principles like
Freedom inequality that like you don't
think about how to actually put them
into practice
the first leftist purity test
for the revolution they were short on
bread and
that sort of stuff I mean I I just want
to emphasize reading these texts on
their own terms and with a historical
grain of salt I guess would have been
the better preface because this has led
to some you know amazing developments
and some nasty [__] too or at least some
frustrating and intractable kinds of
like narratives like the the state of
nature thing being kind of taken a bit
too literally sometimes which is a
problem we should read these texts on
their own terms and he says right near
the beginning the investigations we may
enter into in treating this subject must
not be considered as historical truths
but only as mere conditional and
hypothetical reasonings rather
calculated to explain the nature of
things
which I don't understand how you can do
that without a historical truth but okay
we'll give them that then to ascertain
their actual origin it's rather to
explain the nature of things than to
ascertain their actual origin right he's
not looking for the moment or the the
historical moment these things all
started he's just trying to
you know say if it was this way then how
would it have happened like there's
something wrong with like the you know
everybody's vicious and then society
makes everything all right kind of what
if we kind of thought about this a
different way what would come out of it
and then so he makes all these
distinctions we kind of went over
there's a lot of them you know
Supernatural gifts versus natural gifts
artificial natural
all that stuff and he he makes these and
you he posits them and you think okay
well what's the warrant for that like
what are you basing this like enormous
distinction between humans and animals
on like for instance like I mean it's
important because it drives this whole
story but
okay but take it on this terms is a
thought experiment then it becomes very
very interesting but don't do what the
modern big history Writers Do and like
feel like you have to choose between
Hobbes and Rousseau because they're not
they're like think of them as you know
totally agree with that think of them as
machinic processes I don't think anyone
writes that I don't know there are no
hobsian roussoians anymore are there I
mean there's probably there's there's
probably we're going to read next week
is going to contradict you on that point
exactly especially when we look at his
quotes from Stephen Pinker oh well thank
you if you want to include
diamonds diamonds and the the the Guns
Germs and Steel guy the Guns Germs and
Steel guys a perfect example of them I
think he was a modern day roussoian and
he says you know sorry Anarchist if you
thought that you know if you thought
that the state of nature and
egalitarianism is gonna be you know a
good thing to fight for well think again
because we need Society like he kind of
says that sort of stuff we need
hierarchy we need indeed
Authority I don't know if they say that
I think he says that those things are
spontaneous and unavoidable not that we
need them they're just unavoidable
is diamonds 2012 large populations can't
function without leaders who make
decisions Executives who carry out the
decisions and bureaucrats who administer
the decisions and laws alas for all you
readers who are anarchists and dream of
living without any state government
those are the reasons why your dream is
unrealistic you'll have to find some
tiny band or some Tiny Tribe willing to
accept you where no one is a stranger
where King's presidents and bureaucrats
are unnecessary well that's got to be
true for large populations and so hit so
diamond and fukuyama kind of are on the
same page about that sort of stuff
I mean that's got to be true like it
depends what you define a large
population but like a nation-state scale
population I mean again this is one of
the things they say a deep deep
assumption we make is that large
populations require centralized
government that's a huge they're going
to point this out as like a major major
assumption that loads of these kinds of
like writers make Francis fukuyama Jared
Diamond Stephen Pinker a lot of them all
actually make the same kinds of
assumptions about these things and they
make the same assumptions about Rousseau
and Hobbes well I think you need to make
an assumption like
based on what we know and then I think
if the burden of proof is kind of on the
people who want to say that that's not
the case right like because like all of
our all of our first-hand experience
with history shows that to be true
so like it's I think it's Justified to
make that assumption and then it's kind
of if you want to come in and say that's
wrong well fine
yeah that's the purpose they're saying
there's been a lot of stuff going on in
archeology in the last few decades that
people seem to be completely ignoring it
only goes around in specialist circles
I'm just this book is to bring us up to
date and tell us why the actual facts of
History contradict these sorts of ideas
sure sure I'm just saying I'm just
defending the fact that it's okay to
that it makes sense to make that
assumption I'm not I'm not saying that
for sure that assumption is wrong
sure
you mean the way they put it is is
better we'll get to that next week the
Rousseau what did he have to go on like
he he talks about comparative anatomy
And how it's in such a baby state that
he can't use it for this I I will say I
will say going into next week I mean one
thing I wanted to say quickly just to I
think Eric and I were talking in shot
like a few days ago like
you know I was saying that Russo is kind
of like a proto-anarco primitivist and I
hope you can see what I meant by that
right like clearly he's kind of saying
that like nature is bad and or he or you
know what I thought he he could go that
way or he could also go libertarian like
he's right on that that uh a forked
division
an authoritarianism well then what he
does argue in the social contract ends
up being none of those things like it
just ends up being like a weird kind of
collectivist but in anticipation of next
week like
I did uh read I remember a while ago the
first bit of that dawn of everything
book and yeah it was interesting I'm
going to reread it but like I don't know
I find myself to be generally a skeptic
when people make try to make broad
sweeping claims based on anthropological
evidence there's just so much [__]
like people make so many [__] claims
there's like a long tradition of people
selectively choosing for whatever true
for whatever conclusion they want to
make right like I think conservatives
will cherry pick certain kinds of
anthropological evidence left Wingers
will I don't know we'll see I mean maybe
I'll be impressed but in general like I
find I find myself being kind of like oh
maybe I don't know depends how you read
the evidence yeah I think uh I think
you'll be happy to know that you
basically just paraphrased something
they laid out exactly okay cool he says
you know these these people tend to take
the evidence but then they don't go to
other disciplines and they interpret the
data very narrowly
and he says it's time to you know do a
bit of synthesizing basically that's
what they're thinking about get get all
the evidence and synthesize despite the
criticism of Rousseau they want to be
more like Rousseau in telling a
different Grand narrative from the
accepted Grand narrative but they're
still giving
purposiveness or at least critiquing the
propulsiveness of history that every
single one of these authors engages in
and of course they would
even though he's an anti-enlightenment
thinker he's still an Enlightenment
thinker he's an anti-enlightenment
Enlightenment thinker Rousseau is
yeah speaking of did you know that he
was the one who coined the phrase not
Marie Antoinette but him let them eat
cake let them eat cake oh really that's
funny I didn't know that and at the time
Mary Antoinette was was only nine years
old but it was brioche he said let them
meet brioche a princess said and then
that was later attributed to Marie
Antoinette having said it despite the
fact that she was I don't even think in
France at the time [__] happens
yeah quotable quote
but anyway I think we are at time so
based or so
or are you not convinced Eric
I think yeah I'll say I'll say he's
based but he's not his his base is uh is
pretty thin I mean if you read him like
a contemporary then it's like an insane
person
but if you read him in the context of
who he was writing against and with and
what he was saying as opposed to them I
mean it's a lot of sugar after reading
this I think I can read a lot of
contemporaries his 18th century authors
that's for sure
because because a lot of these are very
familiar tropes in terms of
so it's it's not like uh well he's an
anti-stem Lord like even the stuff about
imagination where he's like imagination
is what we were talking about last week
for example imagination is not only
something to be banished it's the
primary mover for like any human
creative activity and any human activity
at all if you take away imagination then
humans are not human anymore as opposed
to reason being this primary function
that all people practice in and strive
to accomplish in their little civilized
University classrooms that's interesting
because he says here as well every
general idea is purely intellectual if
the imagination meddles with it ever so
little the idea immediately becomes
particular
so if he's saying the imagination makes
us focused on particular things General
ideas are are
like basically irrelevant until the
imagination takes hold of them and and
puts them to particular kinds of uses
and things right
like he's his his examples yeah Trace in
your mind the image of a tree and you'll
never attain your end you can't sleep
I don't know it's it's a weird uh I
don't know what's going on with some of
his um empirical Theory here but um
sure the overall the overall message is
uh inequality is an intractable element
of of modern society
and this is why we're going to learn why
all right let's wrap it up there uh
don't go outside guys take care of
yourself unless you wanna
yeah don't touch any [__] grass today
or unless you're on the West Coast or
whatever unless it's cannabis is that
why it's so dark outside is it because
of the
doesn't seem that dark to me I don't
know it was raining but it's dull and
hazy out there I can see blue skies
literally from my Windows really no oh
you're on the other side of town from us
I'm facing west I can't see [__] I see
gray only gray only anyway
um listeners please enjoy uh a continual
toilet flush of civilization seems like
Civilization collapses every month now
instead of every generation but uh stay
tuned
all right one of those boards up days
without collapse one all right later
guys
bye
[Music]